hello welcome back to GameSpot's
continuing coverage of e3 2015 we saw so
many games at the various conferences
that some of them just got crammed in a
little bit I'm one of those games that I
really wanted to see more of was Riggs
being developed out of a gorilla
Cambridge I'd no idea at Tom and Pierce
thank you so much for coming on the
gamespot stage today to tell us and more
about it and I want to know more about
it so this is a 3v3 app Morpheus VR
arena combat nonsense tell me about it
that's right so yeah we're we're here
showing Riggs it's a first-person arena
based combat shooter exclusively from
Orpheus and we've chosen to set this
game 50 years in the future we're
colliding elements of shooting and sport
high-end cars except crushing them all
together to create these super exciting
sports with superstars battling it out
in combat arenas I like how the effect
you guys have used of kind of jumping in
and making it nice and like the sport
motif I was trying to think of other
first-person shooters who have done it
there was something I used to play in
the late 90s that was kind of like that
it was an online game but you don't
really see it very often it's like most
shooters especially competitive shooters
are kind of needy are kind of gritty or
like early you know based on some sort
of war be it a real one or a fictional
one hey you guys are kind of just having
fun with it I think one of the things we
wanted to do is do something a bit
different as well I mean everyone loved
mex but you know there are a lot of met
games too and we felt there is an
opportunity on Morpheus to push the
boundaries a bit more and not do kind of
traditional slow pace kind of war mix
and I only do something that's much more
agile and and sewing where you can kind
of really explore the arena and faster
more intuitive ways and that's what led
us on to the kind of sporting mex that
you pilots you're the guy who's driving
the Met can you're like the sports star
in it and that's what I think is really
kind of cool I'm very fortunate of my
position in the industry to be able to
like get access to this type of kid i'm
at GDC and the Morpheus was was was
adding in full fashion for people to use
and I've used it I know what it feels
like but it must be difficult to try and
like sell the idea of VR to to gamers
because it's kind of one of these things
where you don't really know until you
pop the head
said I'm it's almost impossible I mean
we've struggled various times to show
this off which is why it's so cool we're
actually III doing this now because the
best way to explain is for people to put
the kid on to play it and for us as
developers watching the reactions when
people are taking it off and just go and
that's most amazing thing I've ever seen
that's what it's about that's where the
arse that and that's what more fish is
really pushing you kind of get a bit you
get bit conditioned to it so seeing
people's first time experience where it
is sunny the magic and they're pointing
stuff out and forget it's on them it
since this release like seeing
shell-shocked you're just used to it
after a while just seasoned pros yeah
yeah and so tell me that headless
controls because anytime I've used the
the Morpheus I've used PlayStation Move
controllers and it's been like 12 1
presumably with being a having to like
walk around in arena you guys are using
a dualshock 4 right so we've we've gone
through a number of control iterations
and you know we're pre-alpha them and it
was still working on it but one of the
things we found most intuitive is
actually just looking and that being
where you want to go and it feels crazy
cuz people go you're making a shooter
you use the right stick for turning yeah
but we found it's super intuitive that
you you look and push forward and you
head in a direction and wherever you
actually focus your head that's where
your guns are pointing and it gives very
very precise shooting really quick so
why are you guys using the move
controllers then don't move to do you
are using the but you're also using the
head tracking us because presumably
that's that I guess that's a massive
sort of design hurdle is because the way
first person shooters look is that your
crosshair is always in the center of
where you're looking but virtual reality
can't look working that way right what
we've learned through this process and
what everyone that's developing on
Morpheus is that all the things you know
indesign go out the window start again
you build these things from the ground
up and you have got a tailor the
experience for Morpheus you've got to
build a game that works for it so when
people told me oh you know I want to
play it with dual sticks it's like we
played that yeah again we're making is
better it just really is excellent am is
this only going to come out on Morpheus
so you guys going to have a version
that's just like for people using on a
dualshock so at the minute we're we're
exclusively time ting Morpheus and
that's taking every single waking hour
about developer how big is the team in
Cambridge we're about 80 at the man AZ
okay so it's not that big when you're
considering how much technical expertise
you is required to use this new
technology how do you guys feel about
the state of virtual reality because I
think a lot of us in the press thought
that like III 2015 was going to be the
year that VR really was sold but
actually it feels like that's probably
gonna be next year because we're we're
gonna see oculus in q1 next year
Morpheus we don't have a date we don't
have a price we don't know when it's
going to come out and like even sup with
valve V or like it's going to come out
but nobody really knows for you guys
when you're making this game I'm sure
you don't have any clue when you're
going to release it or any of that but
when you're making this I do you feel
like you're making a game for a
technology that's finished or do you
feel like you're sort of evolving while
the hardware changes when I think you
guys piss that it's a massive learning
curve so you know it's only recently we
got the latest Morpheus kits and that in
itself is all we need to adjust certain
things and comfort levels and so it's
taking that experience and then kind of
really fine tuning stuff and that's kind
of what's exciting now we're getting
feedback from people who are playing it
where our selves are learning and so we
can kind of build on that momentum I
think kind of the touch on your point
about VR what VR needs is proper game
experiences and yeah I think certainly
the reaction we've been getting from
people is that you know Riggs feels like
a proper game that they can play with
their friends and it's not just the kind
of demo like you know we had some guys
this morning who literally ran in to get
to the front of the queue so they could
play against they played it yesterday
and yeah that's a good sign for bi oh
they played a yesterday around until it
again that's pretty actually I kid
especially considering when you run into
this room there's about a dozen amazing
games that you get to choose from and
let's talk a little bit at the actual
game modes that are in and i know you're
doing like a 3d three thing over there
and how big do you expand that because
honestly when I saw your trailer and I
saw it was just like a small group of
people playing I was kind of refreshing
like so many games are getting really
big like halo now is a big 24 player and
experience so what are you guys going to
do is it scalable or is it very much
like a small tight team based game I
wouldn't classify as a small game but
the the main thing is it's a team-based
going we want this to feel like a sport
we played with the numbers we've added
smaller numbers we've got to increase
the numbers we
she found that three is a really really
good way of being able to coordinate
team activity so you can get people
working on defense on attacking and
that's the number we settle on just
because the game modes work really
really well it's also a good number for
juggling in virtual reality you know
when you're on more fish there's a lot
of information to take yes so being able
to understand where your team are and
where the opposition are is really
really important excellent is this a
game where you i'm not sure how early
you guys are on in terms of like actual
game modes themselves but is this a one
and gone you die or do you respawn when
you when you get killed and you're back
in the game so we have no death in the
game at all you know we're which a
sports game it'd be crazy people dying a
hoot sign up for that sport so when when
your rig takes enough damage you reject
an amazing sequence of fires you up in
the air usually catches everyone it's a
big one moment in virtuality chorus yeah
and then you you get to look into the
arena choose a location and you respawn
then we fly you and descend you into
your new rig that console like it it's
like it's like batman arkham knight you
get shot it at a Batmobile you just land
back in and the other side I almost and
gentlemen thank you so much for coming
on and telling us all about Riggs well
before I let you go what is your sense
when you're showing people these games
when people cvr for the first time I
know I played the M the London heist mo
on move on move and it really just
things you don't really think about like
looking at somebody and then they
realize that they're looking at you and
the eye contact and that the character
kind of says stop looking at me rather
like there's so many ways in which games
can be different on via or unique of
your that you can't do on a regular game
what is your experience being in that
booth watching people at enjoying VR and
what's your biggest take away from that
I think it's one of the things you come
here a lot about games is that they're
kind of immersive or unique em and
actually it's not doing all that time
but FBR I genuinely think it is true and
that's like the most exciting thing and
you know we talked about you don't get
the experience until you put it on you
have to try it to see it um and so yeah
seeing those reactions that's that is
the coolest thing there's a bit of magic
this you do have to try it's amazing
excellence at riggs we'll see it some
station if he goes have done of a date
or anything at this stage day and we do
not know so obviously gorilla has a
wonderful relation
ship with sony is this a project that
you're definitely going to be doing on
playstation it's a morpheus exclusive or
fees exclusive all right at Pearson Tom
thank you so much thank ya thank you and
thanks for coming over to the e3 all the
way over from Cambridge and I really
looking forward to seeing more from
breaks you guys are great are doing some
really interesting stuff thank you very
much must be one time and we are still
here on the gamespot stage all day long
fifa and madden coming up next and we've
also got no man's sky on later on today
speaking of London ish based developers
and alienation czar later pro evolution
soccer is on to we are Madden our next
so stay tuned we back in just a minute